KRISTIN DAVIS: Hi, everybody.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
KRISTIN DAVIS: You're very
impressive with your laptops.
It's like we're at school
DIANE SOLINGER: Well, to
formally welcome you, welcome
to this Talk at Google.
I'm Diane Solinger.
I'm the manager of Googler
Social Responsibility.
Our team is the one that is
launching and hosting the
Hunger Relief campaign
that you may have
seen throughout Google.
And this is a part
of the campaign.
There's a three legged
stool with the
Hunger Relief campaign.
It's about learning
about the issue.
And then it's about taking some
action, giving, and also
volunteering.
And there's been amazing
activities across Google over
the course of the last month,
where Googlers are stepping up
to donate, to take the quiz to
learn more about hunger.
And then we make a gift
on your behalf.
Or to volunteer in their local
communities, kind of
culminating next week with Alan
Eustace's huge food drive
here on the Mountain
View campus.
So thank you all for being a
part of the Hunger Relief
campaign, and for
being Googlers.
You're fantastic and charitable
people that amaze
me every day at the interest
and the spirit and kind of
this unbridled will to try to
save the world and do great
things in the world every day.
And thank you for being a part
of the Hunger Relief campaign.
If you want to learn more
about it, you just go to
Hunger Relief.
And there's been some things
on your chair, as well.
Take the quiz. $10 will be
donated to a project of your
choosing through a global
giving platform.
Some of the Oxfam projects
are actually
listed there, as well.
So to kick off today, I'm just
going to introduce who our
panelists are.
We have a wonderful panel
discussion here.
Introducing Kristin Davis, star
of "Sex in the City" and
ambassador for Oxfam America.
KRISTIN DAVIS: Hi,
how are you?
I'm happy to be here.
I have been to New
York Google.
I'm getting educated
on the Googlers.
I'm very impressed.
DIANE SOLINGER: We're impressed
with you, too, for
doing what you're doing.
We have Ray Offenheiser, who is
the CEO of Oxfam America.
And Kristin serves as ambassador
for Oxfam America.
And she'll talk a little bit
about her experiences.
Susan Godwin is a farmer from
Nigeria who is really someone
who's going to tell us her
personal story about hunger
relief, and how she's really
making a go as a small farmer
in her country and in her
community, and getting others
inspired to do the same.
And we have Aarti Sequeira.
Did I say it right?
Close?
AARTI SEQUEIRA: Sequeira.
DIANE SOLINGER: Sequeira.
AARTI SEQUEIRA: It's
fine, it's fine.
DIANE SOLINGER: So sorry.
AARTI SEQUEIRA: You got
the first name.
DIANE SOLINGER: But you're
Aarti Party, right?
AARTI SEQUEIRA: People
have asked me if
party's my last name.
DIANE SOLINGER: She's
the host of "Aarti
Party" on the Food Network.
And was the winner of season
six of the "Next Great Food
Network Star," right?
Fantastic.
So going to start
really with an
opening question to Kristin.
Because your story of getting
involved with Oxfam, choosing
Oxfam, and then some of the
experiences that you have.
We'd love to just start with
you, and hear why, and what
you're doing.
KRISTIN DAVIS: Absolutely.
After the tsunami in 2004, I
believe it was, in Indonesia,
I was doing some research about
who would be staying in
the region and helping
the farmers get
their businesses back.
Because I'd been to Indonesia,
and I knew how they lived.
And how basic their
businesses were.
And how it had really been taken
away by the tsunami.
And while giving to
organizations that do the
immediate relief in a
devastating situation is
obviously important, it's also
important to think about
helping the people develop their
businesses back so that
they can be self-sustaining.
And what I learned in that
research was that Oxfam kind
of specializes in that.
We specialize in a
lot of things.
We do do immediate disaster
relief as well.
But we stayed in Indonesia
for eight years?
Five years.
And then we continued on.
We're still there.
And after Katrina, we stayed in
New Orleans and the whole
Gulf region for five years as
well, helping people get their
lives back and their
businesses back.
So that's the thing for me that
I think is so special and
impressive.
Because it's not an
easy thing to do.
You really have to commit.
You really have to be in a
region and understand the
culture and the people and
what's going on for them.
And kind of be able to do a lot
of different things to be
able to help people be
self-sustaining,
which is the goal.
Our goal is not to create a
culture of need, where you're
constantly needing an
aid organization.
We want people to be back up on
their feet, which is what
people all over the world that
I've met my travels with Oxfam
want as well.
Everybody wants to work.
Everybody, as we will hear
today, wants to be able to
make a living and feed
their family.
And that's what Oxfam tries to
help people do if they're in a
situation where they can't.
So that's, personally,
what I really love.
I've traveled all around the
world, predominately Africa.
I focus on women's issues.
Because they really
affect everyone.
They affect the children.
They affect the next
generation.
And there's obviously many,
many issues for
women around the world.
And I love it.
If I could just quite my regular
job, sometimes, I
would just try to be Ray.
Though I would never
live up to him.
That was a short story.
Tell me, anything else?
DIANE SOLINGER: No,
that's fantastic.
So with respect to women and
some of the women that you've
met in your travels, I saw a
part of the BBC clip when you
were in a refugee camp.
Was that near Somalia, Somalian
refugees in Kenya?
Or where was that?
KRISTIN DAVIS: Those words
Somalian refugees in Kenya,
just over the border
from Somalia.
And that was actually a trip
that I had gone on to go to
Tanzania to launch the Female
Food Hero, which is what Susan
ended up winning, which was a
competition we were having for
female farmers, which is now
a huge predominance of the
farmers in especially
sub-Saharan Africa.
But all over the world, most
of the farmers and small,
private farms are women now,
which is a little known fact,
and quite fascinating.
And we were there, we were
meeting these incredibly
successful women farmers
in Tanzania.
They were growing 12
different crops.
They were feeding their families
and their sisters'
families and everyone's
families.
And it was very inspiring.
And at the same time, this
horrible drought was unfolding
in Northern Africa.
And we were getting these
numbers of how many people
were flooding into Dadaab.
So we were so close that we
decided that we should go and
try to see the situation
for ourselves.
And when we got there, is was
a really horribly shocking
contrast to see the number of
people who literally had no
safety net available to them in
any way for themselves or
their children or
their families.
I could talk for an
hour about it.
But it was shocking that in a
modern world that we live in
today, where things are
accessible, there is enough
food to feed everyone
in the world.
Yet, it is not available to
everyone in the world.
And to see just the dire, dire,
dire circumstances of
those people was really
heart-wrenching.
Everyone tries to keep me
from talking about this.
Because I can't talk about
it without crying.
But it is the truth.
I mean, there are
really shocking
situations that happen.
And there are a lot of people
who are trying to help.
So it's great to be part of
the trying to help group.
DIANE SOLINGER: Absolutely.
And kind of the longer term
sustainability piece of it is
what Susan's representing.
You mentioned women taking care
of their families, their
communities, bringing others
in through farming.
So tell us about your
experiences, Susan.
And what's happening in your
life, because your life's
really been transformed.
SUSAN GODWIN: Good afternoon.
I'm Susan Godwin, a small scale
farmer from Nigeria.
In fact, I was farming for
more than 10 years.
But I don't have enough food
to eat with my family
[INAUDIBLE]
to send my kids to school.
Not until when I meet with the
Oxfam program, which was sent
down to my community,
of which I enrolled
myself into the program.
And after receiving all the
training, the training was all
about capacity building for
small scale farmers, which I
adopt a new method of farming.
We are also trained to do some
little business attached to
our farm work.
And also train to add a little
value to whatever we produce,
so that we can have
more money.
So when I get that knowledge, I
quickly put it into practice.
And I see my lifestyle
was changing.
I can be able to feed
my family well.
Assist other women in my
community to take good care of
their own family, too.
And my life was changed to
good with my community.
So that is the short story
I have to give for now.
Maybe later, I explain more.
DIANE SOLINGER: Susan,
what are your crops?
Because you had to learn a whole
new way of farming, but
then you also changed what you
were planting, correct?
So you're growing what?
What do you grow?
SUSAN GODWIN: My major crop I
grow was yam and peanuts.
I farm a little of sorghum to
feed my family, and cassava.
But the major crop was
yam and peanuts.
It wasn't even enough for
me to eat with my
family at the beginning.
But now, things change.
DIANE SOLINGER: And you're
selling peanut butter, peanut
oil, right?
And you're leasing
your equipment to
other people now, too?
So you've got a business
going on here.
SUSAN GODWIN: Yeah, yeah.
So when I quickly adopt that
methods, for the first year,
my harvest change.
I was having no less than, or
not more than five bags of
dried peanuts in the year.
But now, I have up to
17 for that year.
And my yam, I normally
get less than 1,000
tubers of yam a year.
But I was able to get up to
2,000 for that year, which I
know I have much money.
I have to sell some of the crops
that I produce to buy a
machine, to add value to my
own peanuts that I grow.
So the first machine,
I was using it.
And I was the first person
to start that
business in my community.
So the business was
moving so fast.
I was doing it commercially for
people, and use this to do
my own personal groundnut that
I found from the farm also to
get more money.
And out of the money,
I work for people.
I normally buy some of the
groundnut and so add to my own
when the market goes up.
Then I sell it to
have more money.
So I was doing it like that
for the first year.
The second year, I now
have much money.
I have to go and buy five more
machine, which I need to add
more value to my peanuts.
This time around, I wanted
to maybe struck
oil out of the peanuts.
And have the oil, and sell
out the groundnut.
So this time, the
machine are six.
And I needed more hand to
operate the machine.
I have to employ other women.
Give them a little chance of job
opportunity, so that they
will work on the machine.
And I get them paid at
the end of the day.
So while we are doing this, I
also get them into group and
encourage them that the money
they are getting, they should
not spend it all.
But they should try to
be saving something.
So that they can have money to
start their own businesses, of
which they did.
After the first year, they have
a little morning that
they can start their
own businesses.
After one, two, three years,
some of them now have their
personal machine that
they are working on.
And they even employed other
less privileged women, too, to
work for them.
And they get them paid.
They also encourage them to do
some group savings, so that at
the end of the year, they can
also get something to start
their own business with.
So this has been helping us.
Before, no money.
The men take charge of
everything that we have.
If they want, they only train
the boys, leaving the girls
that their education has
more value, go to
their husband's house.
So we women, so far in
it, we don't have
means to help our daughters.
We look at it, so far, we may
not want our daughter to come
and face the same
thing tomorrow.
So with this little chance I
have, I now put more knowledge
on the women that we should
train our ladies so that
tomorrow, they will help our
community and help fight back
this bad situation that
we are living in.
Because down there in Nigeria,
you find out what the woman
has is for the man and
not for the woman.
You don't have right
to spend whatever
you have for yourself.
Let's say that I have
a model now.
I have much money.
I want to build a house
for my mother.
I cannot do it-- or
for my father--
unless my husband agreed
before I will do it.
So that has been a problem.
We now look at it, if we can
send our daughters to school,
maybe tomorrow they will
know their rights.
They will know how to fight
this thing back.
And they will live better
than we are doing now.
So in most of the communities,
there are a lot of challenges
in doing this.
Because the men normally come
to me and say, Susan, you
better stop this thing
that you are
putting our wives into.
Why do you make them to
come and work for
you and have money?
Our wives, we are [INAUDIBLE]
to ask all this.
When we tell them to
eat, they eat.
When we tell them not to
eat, they sleep hungry.
Why are you forcing them to
eat all the time now?
They are our wives, making
troubles with us because they
have something at hand.
We don't want it.
We want you to stop it.
What I always tell them is, they
should be kind with them.
Because the women also
have rights.
They want something that will
help their future and their
children, also.
So I talk to some of
them in that way.
And some get to understand.
Now, they are saying, Susan,
don't forget our wives.
Because our wives help us to
take care of our family.
If there is anything good, you
try to let our wives know so
that you can carry them along.
But some up to now, they
don't understand.
They keep on fighting.
At times, they even
harass my husband.
You should tell your wife Susan
to stop taking our wives
outside, even those
[INAUDIBLE].
So it has been like that.
But the more hands that are
coming in, and the women are
getting what they want, and
taking good care of their
family, I think almost all the
problem is coming to an end.
Now the women themselves
have a lot of
machines they work on.
So when I was seeing my market
cannot longer move as it is
before, we have more than 50
houses now that have a machine
on their own to operate.
Just because of one particular
person that start their
business, the business is all
over the community now and
around the community.
So I quickly leave that
business on to them.
I jump into selling
the machine parts.
Because when--
DIANE SOLINGER: You
are so smart.
This is one smart entrepreneur
here.
SUSAN GODWIN: You have to travel
to the town if you are
buying a lot of tatsi Naira.
I don't know how to say your
money, so please pardon me.
If you are buying a lot
of tatsi Naira.
You have to spend 300 Naira.
To go to the town, your
transportation, before buying
that note of tatsi Naira.
So instead of that, I then
bought the spare parts of the
machine from the town,
and bring it and sell
at 40 Naira to them.
So to help them to save
their transport.
And my market is also moving.
So one of the challenges I
have, after attending the
World Food Prize in Iowa, when
I went back home on the 24th
of December, when I gathered
some men to go and help me do
my heaps in my farm, only to go
there to discover that the
heaps that was done on my behalf
by my husband, the heap
was destroyed.
So they now quickly call my
attention that my heap has
been destroyed.
Am I aware of it?
I say I don't.
So when I went, I went to the
person that I hired the land.
Because as a woman, you
don't own a land.
You have to hire from the
men, and work on it.
And where you want to hire, the
men now make sure that the
land they give you is not
the fertile land.
Because they don't want you
to get enough crop.
Where you get so much harvest,
maybe you will
look down on them.
So the land that was
given to me--
DIANE SOLINGER: A lot of social
norms that you're
trying to change while
you're doing this.
It's hard.
SUSAN GODWIN: So from that,
the heaps was destroyed.
And what I get to do now,
I now buy cow, two
of the young cow.
Because when I was here,
I was taken to farms.
I see so many farms with
rearing animals.
I said, OK.
If there will no land, that
will not wear me down.
Let me transfer to animal.
So that is what I'm
trying to do now.
Thank you.
DIANE SOLINGER: Wow.
Three businesses
going on there.
Phew!
Thank you.
KRISTIN DAVIS: What a great,
great story, Susan.
You're so impressive.
Wow.
DIANE SOLINGER: So Ray, let's
kind of take it up a level.
And talk about the whole, the
food system in general.
And give us, first of all,
Oxfam's mission, what you do,
why you exist.
And then explain to us the whole
systematic issue with
respect to the fact that there's
enough food in the
world, but it's not getting
to everybody.
RAYMOND OFFENHEISER: Well, first
of all, I just want to
say, just thinking a little bit
about Susan's story, what
you're looking at here is an
entrepreneur, feminist, and a
human rights activist all
rolled up into one.
So kind of an interesting
embodiment of
what we're after here.
Let me just quickly, Oxfam's an
international development,
humanitarian organization.
And our mission is really, in
some ways, to echo what Susan
said, to create lasting
solutions to hunger, poverty,
and social injustice.
Not to actually be remaining
in these countries forever.
Our hope is that one day, we
leave and people like Susan
are sort of taking over and
running the country, and
providing food for their
population in ways that are
going to meet everyone's
needs.
We live and work in
those regions.
And so we know the hunger and
poverty challenges quite well.
There's 900 million people
in the world
today that are hungry.
This is a UN statistic that's
pretty recognized.
It's a very, very big number,
almost a billion.
In fact, it crossed
a billion in 2008
with the hunger crisis.
And it's fallen back a bit as
conditions have gotten a
little bit better.
I think one of the great ironies
that Kristin actually
mentioned is the fact that we
live in a world where actually
there is enough food
to go around.
And the issues of hunger have
more to do oftentimes with
justice and access than they
have to do with pure supply.
And we saw that dramatically
with the food
price crisis in 2008.
It wasn't a question
of supply.
It was a question of whether
people could actually afford
to buy the food.
And so for us, the real issues
around hunger are not just
simply whether we produce
enough, or a
pure nutrition problem.
It's actually a justice
question.
And it's oftentimes about issues
that we don't often
talk about when we talk
about food and hunger.
We think all we need to do
is provide more food.
And actually, that may
not be the solution.
It's often about justice.
It's about access, about
market failure.
It's about policies.
It's about abuse of power
in different contexts.
Whole range of complicated
issues that sort of constitute
the reasons in different
national contexts why people
aren't getting food, and aren't
adequately nourished.
At the end of the day, these are
the kinds of issues that
Oxfam tries to address
in our policy work.
And we can talk a little bit
more about that further into
the conversation.
But I think maybe the bottom
line here is if we're going to
win the global hunger game, if
I can call it that, I think
what we need to be really
thinking about is changing the
rules which enable people to get
access, get investment of
the sort that you just heard
Susan getting, and taking
advantage of those investments,
investing in
women, and thinking about how we
deal with some of the other
big challenges like
climate change
that loom on the horizon.
And the big challenge, maybe
thinking forward, is we will
be a world with 9 billion
people by 2050.
And there's some real challenges
as to how we're
going to feed that 9
billion by 2050.
And when we think about issues
of climate change, impacts on
environment, impacts on
productivity, do we have the
approaches and the will to
meet that challenge?
DIANE SOLINGER: It really is,
it's a right to have food.
Right?
RAYMOND OFFENHEISER: Some
countries, actually, the
interesting thing is India has
actually made food a right.
And they're trying
to figure out--
there you go.
And it's an interesting
question.
One of the things Oxfam had come
to realize was that there
are a whole--
when the Human Rights Charter
was signed in 1947, it was
about civil and political
rights.
But it was also about social,
economic, and cultural rights.
But during the Cold War,
we lost sight of that.
But at the end of the Cold War,
I think there's a real
opportunity to ask questions
like, should there be a right
to education?
Should there be a
right to food?
Some of these basic needs.
Or a right to health services.
And other countries around
the world are
actually embracing this.
And the right to food is one
that, in the case of India,
has been embraced.
And actually, they have programs
now to be executed to
actually realize that right
for their population.
They're not always working as
well as they could, but they
are, in fact, under way.
DIANE SOLINGER: So at Oxfam,
you're kind of dealing
literally at the highest policy
level, but also in
supporting courses like
Susan took to
transform the way she farms--
this whole spectrum of ways of
dealing with the issues.
RAYMOND OFFENHEISER: What we've
learned over the years
is we can't solve these kinds of
issues at the local level.
In some ways, we could have
great programs, and we did for
many, many years at the village
level, and in certain
regions of countries.
But we could address those
problems and have the sort of
satisfaction that we've solved
the problem in a sort of, if
you will, an island
of well being
surrounded by a sea of misery.
And we realized that we had to
look beyond the problem at the
local level, and figure out
what was actually keeping
those people poor.
Why were they not accessing
inputs for agriculture, or
credit And the answer we came
up with was that poverty is
not necessarily about
the absence of
those goods for people.
It's about questions
of access.
And we end up defining poverty
as social exclusion.
And then trying to figure out,
if poverty is social
exclusion, that means there are
certain barriers that are
limiting people's access.
And so what are those
barriers?
How can they be addressed?
Oftentimes, they're about
ethnic conflict.
Sometimes, they're about
policies that
governments have in place.
And it leads us to be much more,
I suppose you might say,
systems thinkers, like many of
you here in the room are, in
thinking about the
poverty problems.
And trying to sort of analyze,
what are the big systemic
barriers that can unleash the
kind of human potential that
you just heard unleashed in
Susan's African village?
Just think about what has been
spawned by her initiative and
those of her sisters in her
particular village.
And why wasn't that happening
a long time ago?
What was limiting that
from happening?
And how can we help we attack
these kinds of issues
systemically, and leverage
far greater change?
DIANE SOLINGER: My team knows
I'm a big fan of this book
called "Switch," which Chip and
Dan Heath wrote, very much
focused on the idea
of bright spots.
Susan's a bright spot.
It works.
So how does Oxfam, or how do
you in your celebrity, and
you, Aarti, as well, how do
you take something that's
working well, and share that
story so that it is
replicated?
And find out the things that
made that, what was the secret
sauce with Susan's, that
made it work for her?
KRISTIN DAVIS: Well, I think,
Ray is our president, right,
of Oxfam America?
So luckily, he is incredibly
knowledgeable about
everything, which is amazing.
And to pick his brain is
a wonderful thing.
And he can deal up here
on the policy level.
I do not mess with that.
I let the professionals
do that.
What I get to do is I get to
meet people like Susan in
their villages, in their
countries, and see what just
some knowledge, some
effort, can do.
And to me, it's completely life
changing for me, as well.
Because it doesn't take--
I feel like sometimes what
happens for us here in
America, I know for me before
I started my travels with
Oxfam, you feel like these
issues are overwhelming.
And that they cannot
be changed.
And why should we try?
Sometimes, you get
really down.
Like it just seems like there's
so many problems in
the world, and even in
our own country.
You're just overwhelmed.
But once you go out and you see
how hard people want to
work-- like Susan was
there, wanting to
work this whole time.
But because we've seen time
after time after time when the
husband are like, no, no, no.
And you're like, why would you
say no to your woman starting
a business?
It is so crazy for
us to think that.
But there are really ingrained
social issues.
Like if a woman is not
allowed to own land,
just mull that over.
I've been to so many countries
where that's true.
Where their husbands might die,
they and their children
are kicked out of the house.
And the husband's family takes
the house and the land.
And that's just how it is.
Then a little bright spot, as
you said, Mozambique, which
was one of my first trips, a
group of women lawyers had
left Mozambique to get
their law degrees.
And had come back to
help their country.
And part of what they did was
they really focused on trying
to change the law so that
women could own land.
So they worked very hard
for a very long time.
And they eventually did
change this law.
But the problem being, nobody
knew that the law was changed.
Partly because there are 26, I
think, local tribal languages
in Mozambique, something
like that.
And they are really hard
to understand.
And so no one was really
communicating with everybody.
And also, they couldn't
read the papers.
So what these women lawyers then
thought, and this is part
of what I love about Oxfam,
is they helped them.
They thought, well, we need
to get the word out there.
How could we do that?
We could start a radio program,
where different
people would come
who spoke these
different tribal languages.
And talk about it, so that
people might hear it.
Then the next thing they did,
which we got to see, was they
started a little theater
troupe that
would go to the villages.
And you'd sit on the ground, and
the little theater troupe
would come in.
It would be all women.
And the women would dress
up as the men.
And they'd do, [GRUMBLING].
It was like a comedy thing.
But it was all about AIDS.
So all of us were like,
should we laugh?
What should we do?
It was really confusing.
But it was about how the husband
dies of AIDS, and then
the woman feels she must marry
the brother so that she
doesn't get kicked
out of the house.
And then, a woman would come
in and say, no, no, no, you
don't have to.
You can own the land.
And everyone would
be like, ahh!
And we were like,
this is amazing.
So it was finding the way to get
the word out that this law
had been changed after these
women worked so hard
to change the law.
And that's Oxfam helping these
people to come up with this
project and that project
to get the job done.
And then you see that women can
own their own land, and
farm, and still have a home
for their children.
And aren't put out on the street
by people who aren't
necessarily nice to them.
What was the question?
I'm so sorry.
DIANE SOLINGER: Fabulous
bright spot there.
KRISTIN DAVIS: Welcome
to my mind.
DIANE SOLINGER: I want to
bring Aarti in to the
conversation, as well.
Because I think there's
this idea of local--
KRISTIN DAVIS: It's just
telling the stories.
That's all.
I'm just here to witness.
DIANE SOLINGER: You tell
great stories, Kristin.
That was awesome.
KRISTIN DAVIS: That is my job.
I am here to witness.
That is how I look at it.
Because I do feel like
it is inspiring.
I feel like, Susan's story, like
hearing Susan's story,
you're like, wow.
I mean, that is amazing.
And I could help somebody
do that.
And that makes you
feel connected.
And it makes you feel hopeful.
So that's how I look
at my job.
DIANE SOLINGER: And Aarti,
I think something--
you're a foodie, let's
face it, right?
But you've also been really a
bit of an activist, I think,
about saying what you can do to
make a difference in your
daily life that helps with food
related security issues.
AARTI SEQUEIRA: Yeah.
I think that, and I don't
think I'm alone here, so
please raise your hand, that
probably the most we've ever
been told growing up about what
we can do about world
food shortages is clean
your plate.
Because there are starving
people in, insert country
here, right?
I mean, who has heard
that growing up?
That is not going
to do anything.
So the thing that I love about
Oxfam and the Grow campaign,
if I can throw that out there,
is that it makes it very easy
for us, here, to make choices
in the way that we shop, the
way that we cook, the way that
we don't waste quite as much
of our vegetables.
Super guilty of that.
That we can make these very
simple choices, and have a
real ding dang impact on food
shortages around the world.
My dad, his side of the family
is a farming family.
They grew rice.
And so I've heard the stories of
what happens when you don't
have enough rice that year.
It's pretty dire.
So I guess in a way, it's
pretty personal to me.
And so it's very empowering
on this level.
I mean, I think the thing that
is so amazing about listening
to Susan is that she
sounds very proud.
We're not just talking
about food here.
Food is sort of one of those
sacred things where when you
feed somebody, or when you teach
someone how to cook, if
I could be so bold, you're
sort of telling them,
I care about you.
You're important.
And you are able to do
a lot of things.
And I believe in you.
And so I think that
that's why this is
such a powerful campaign.
And--
DIANE SOLINGER: Explain
the Grow campaign
a little bit more.
Because I'm not sure if Googlers
know much about it.
AARTI SEQUEIRA: Well, I I
have a terrible memory.
But--
DIANE SOLINGER: We'll have Ray
here as the backup, right?
AARTI SEQUEIRA: Ray,
back me up, buddy.
So there's five steps.
There's five different
things you can do.
So one of them is, and you
guys might already do it,
meatless Monday.
Not a big deal.
Eat some beans instead
of some meat.
And that, raising meat, takes
up an awful lot of water.
A ton of water.
And so if you just did that, you
can save like 14 bathtubs
of water, just by not eating
meat on Monday.
That's pretty simple, especially
because you guys
have an amazing cafeteria
here.
And the fact is you make
a difference with
the money you spend.
So if once a week, you're not
buying meat, you're telling
people something.
Another thing is
to waste less.
We waste like 1 in 16 apples,
is that right?
So instead of doing
that, buy less.
Go to the store a little
more often.
That's what I do.
And then you have to come
up with a strategy.
So whatever's left at the end of
the week, you make a soup.
Or you make a frittata.
Or you make a scramble.
Or you put it in some sauce
and put it over pasta.
So you just don't waste
those vegetables.
Because it took energy, and it
took money, and it took fuel
to get those vegetables
to you, or whatever
it is you're using.
And then, what's another
one, Roy?
RAYMOND OFFENHEISER:
Buy seasonally.
AARTI SEQUEIRA: Buy
seasonally.
I love this.
I mean, we live in California.
So we're really spoiled
this way.
I was just in Orlando,
and I was like, eeh.
DIANE SOLINGER: Florida,
really?
AARTI SEQUEIRA: No slight
against Orlando.
But I'm just saying, the
things we get at the
supermarket here,
I mean, come on.
It's amazing.
When you buy seasonally, it's
just going to taste better.
Because it's meant to be
growing right now.
It will also be cheaper.
And that also means it took less
energy, and less fuel, et
cetera, et cetera, to grow.
And one of the secrets--
you can just shut
me up any time,
because I'll keep going--
the one thing about cooking
seasonally is it's almost like
God's gift to us.
Because think about what
grows in one season.
So let's take the winter.
"Winter," California
standards.
So you have these hearty
greens like
kale, let's just say.
Kale happens to go wonderfully
with butternut squash, which
happens to go wonderfully with
hearty herbs like sage.
It's almost like God's
like, here you go.
Cook.
It's actually a lot simpler
when you think
about things that way.
And also, when you eat
seasonally, you tend to crave
those things.
So in the summer when it's
hot, you're not craving
butternut squash.
You're craving tomatoes and
cucumbers and watermelons,
very light fruit
and vegetables.
So you are actually doing
your body a service.
And then, here is the thing
that's so awesome, not only
are you doing yourself some
good, you're doing people
across the world from
you some good.
It's like, come on.
It's so easy.
DIANE SOLINGER: And
supporting local
farmers often, too, right?
AARTI SEQUEIRA: Yes.
Buying fair trade and
buying local.
And fair trade chocolate, if
you're not buying chocolate,
now you have your excuse.
DIANE SOLINGER: So Ray, let's
talk about the big farming
issues, the ADMs of the world.
Dare I say ethanol with you?
I know that's kind of maybe a--
no, I shouldn't go there?
But I mean really, when we're
thinking about the systemic
issues with respect to food
and security for food.
And then you have the farming
that we've gone to in most of
the developed world, big,
massive conglomerate farms
versus really what we're talking
about for the rest of
the world, but also for us,
to buy local, small farms.
There's a big kind of---
I don't know.
It's just a rub there, between
big business and really
probably what's maybe the better
thing for all of us.
Tell us where Oxfam stands
on those things.
RAYMOND OFFENHEISER: Well, let
me, since this is a room of
systems thinkers, I was told
everyone at Google's a systems
thinker, I'm going to venture
into this world of talking
about the global food system.
And the fact that we live in a
world where basically, much of
the world subsists on
eight basic grains.
And I'm not going to name
them all for you.
You can probably figure out.
You can start with rice,
wheat, corn, and
go on down the list.
And people eat some 257 other
crops around the world.
But the big grains are
ones that sustain
life around the world.
2008, we had this incredible
event happen, which was that
we suddenly discovered after 30
or 40 years of assuming we
had abundant global food supply,
that those grain
stocks had sort of run out.
And all these economists woke up
one day, and realized, wow.
What happened?
Why are there no sort
of grain stocks?
And when the grain stocks ran
out, the prices started just
to spiral out of control.
And they went up some 300%
around the world.
Now, think about, if
you're Susan, and
you're living in Nigeria.
And you're a subsistence
farmer.
And you're having a bad
year, as Aarti said.
And suddenly, you may have to
buy food in the local market.
And you can't produce
enough to eat.
And the prices have
gone up 300%.
And on average, you generally
spend 75% to 80% of whatever
cash you have on food.
Well, this was like an
impossible situation for poor
families all over the world.
It was a little easier, maybe,
if you were a rural
subsistence farmer.
Because you had some food.
If you were an urban or poor,
you had really no options.
Because there was no
food around you.
So what happened?
38 countries were rioting.
Some people would claim some of
the Arab Spring is related
to, actually, food
price crises.
These prices went up in 2008.
They haven't come down.
So the world is still being
faced with this sort of food
price crisis.
And these stocks have
not been restored.
So what was going on?
And this is where I want to help
link, help you sort of
see some of the linkages.
So that you could sort of
apply all your systems
thinking to kind of thinking
about this food system in a
way that will be helpful to you,
and simplify it for you.
Climate change.
Well, there was a drought in
Australia for seven years, in
the wheat growing regions
of Australia.
The wheat crops collapsed.
And so the wheat prices were
just going up and up and up.
The stocks were falling, falling
down tremendously.
Russia had a drought the winter
after the end of the
Australia droughts.
More crisis in the
wheat markets.
So climate change suddenly is
starting to affect our global
food supply.
So if any of you are wondering
about whether climate change
is real, believe me, in the
world we live in, and we're
looking at these food supplies,
it is really real.
And it's here to stay.
And in places like Africa, in
various parts of it, the
Somalia famine that Kristin
talked about, that was about
climate change impacts in a
drought prone region, where we
used to see droughts
every seven years.
Now we see them every
three years.
Other issue, ethanol.
40% of the corn grown in
the United States goes
into your gas tank.
Why?
Because we have legislation
in the United States that
originally thought was going
to be part of a solution to
the climate problem and
reducing carbon in the
atmosphere.
Turns out, it's not
actually the case.
But we have laws now that
require 10% of every gallon of
gas you put in your gas
tank is ethanol based.
And that is a congressional
mandate that's
going to go up to 15%.
This is the first time in
history we've had a
relationship between
food and fuel.
And we're taking that corn out
of the global food supply.
What's the implication
of that?
Higher prices, because
you have less supply.
So that's another sort
of a critical issue.
Global oil prices, fossil
fuel, and industrial
agriculture, to Diana's point.
This is what has sustained us
here in the United States.
But actually, it's a very
expensive way to do
agriculture.
And when you think about the
fact that you're going to have
increasing demand for fossil
fuels globally, and that
fossil fuels provide inputs for
fertilizers, pesticides,
herbicides, if oil prices keep
going up and up and up, which
they're predicted to do, inputs
for people like Susan
are going to go up and up and
up, which take her out of the
production cycle.
Because she can't afford
the inputs.
Which is also, if you remember,
the fuel prices went
up in 2008, 2009 as well.
So there were all of these
sort of confluent factors
coming together that
drove this crisis.
And it's still staying
with us.
And these are things we've
got to keep an
eye on going forward.
Now, are there some things we
can be thinking about and
doing in order to address
these issues?
One, we need to be thinking
about climate change, and
getting serious about it.
We've got to insure that our
government, this government,
does something about it.
We consume 25% of the world's
energy in fossil fuels.
And that's driving a
lot of this climate
change that we're seeing.
These degree changes that are
being talked about, the
implications for African
countries, Nigeria and other
parts of sub-Saharan Africa,
what are the implications?
More droughts, more frequently,
or extreme rain in
Mozambique and Zimbabwe.
We've seen the other
version of this,
which is massive flooding.
Huh?
DIANE SOLINGER: Just kidding.
Or here today.
RAYMOND OFFENHEISER: Or
here today, exactly.
Massive flooding where
Sandy in New York, or
that part of the world.
You're seeing these kind of
dramatic climatic effects.
The ethanol issue, we actually
have been fighting, Oxfam's
been fighting that one
on Capitol Hill the
last couple of years.
Because of the fiscal crisis,
we won on getting subsidies
cut to the ethanol industry.
Because they kept building
more and
more and more factories.
But we still have
the mandates.
So we've got to get rid
of those mandates.
And that's something--
DIANE SOLINGER: What's happening
in some of your
travels, though, Susan, are you
seeing small farmers doing
biofuels instead of
planting crops?
Any of that happening?
I've read some articles like
in Sierra Leone, that's
happening, where small farmers
are being displaced.
Because biofuel crops are
getting them more money.
KRISTIN DAVIS: Oh yeah,
it's everywhere.
I mean, when you go into a
beautiful country, you'll be
driving along, like Mozambique,
Kenya, I think
every country I've been to,
you'll be driving along.
You'll see beautiful little
farms, little personal farms
like Susan's.
And then you'll see some really
horrible, huge building.
And you'll say, what's that?
And they'll say a company's name
that I don't want to say.
But one of those big
agricultural companies.
And it's not a pretty farm.
It's a horrible, huge building
where they're like controlling
the atmosphere inside
the building.
I mean, it's a shocking thing.
And you think, well, why
are they doing that?
Why don't they just
farm like regular?
Because they're not really
interested in
farming like regular.
So that's sad.
DIANE SOLINGER: It's
displacing farmers.
And it's displacing food,
right, Susan?
Are you seeing that?
SUSAN GODWIN: I would like
to come in mean here.
Because most of the foods, they
buy it from the small
scale farmers.
So they take it there.
They make it to destroy it.
When the price go up,
they now sell it.
So even in Nigeria, this climate
change also affect,
although there was no flood.
But in fact, some of our yam,
yam normally produce from the
soil, got bad this year.
There's no good to have
a yam harvest.
The yam leaves are supposed to
drop by October to December,
where January is due
for harvest.
But our yam leaves started
dropping since July, which
even this year, I don't think,
most of us are going to lose
our seeds, because
of too much rain.
When the rain start, it was
heavily up to when it end.
So everywhere, even where we
have places that water don't
flow before this year, you'll
find water flowing or over
everywhere.
So this is an issue that
need to be addressed.
It's going to cause more problem
to what we are trying
to fight hunger.
And this climate change may
still make it difficult.
KRISTIN DAVIS: Can I just say
one other thing, just to
connect the dots?
Ray and I went up to Capitol
Hill last year on
International Women's Day,
which does exist.
It is real.
Everyone always says, did
you make that up?
No, it exists all the way
around the world.
It's just America, we don't
really celebrate it.
So we decided 100 women from
around the country, with
sisters on the planet,
went to Washington.
And I went with Ray,
so I could learn.
And we were talking to a bunch
of Republicans, actually.
And they were all very nice.
And we were talking about
a lot of these issues.
And one of the things that we
talked about and that they
asked us about, because
sometimes people say, well,
why does it matter to us here
what is happening in Nigeria?
What is happening in Kenya?
Well, first of all, from my
travels, I mean, just as a
human being, I think that
it absolutely matters.
I guess that is a moral decision
that each person has
to make for themselves.
But separate from that, like Ray
was saying, people rioted
over the lack of food
and the food prices.
This--
DIANE SOLINGER: Instability
that it causes.
KRISTIN DAVIS: Thank you,
instability, not disability,
but instability.
Instability is not good for
any of us, anywhere.
And I could go down the
list of things that
have affected us.
Obviously, we all know the
things that have affected us.
But the worse the situations get
in these poor countries--
we are all connected
at this point.
There is no way that we can
say, well, we don't care.
We are not affected by them.
Because we will be, in
one way or another.
And that's why, even separate
from just a humanitarian, I
care about my brother, type of
an idea, which is how I feel,
you also, from a very
real, practical,
monetary, and security--
RAYMOND OFFENHEISER: National
security point of view.
KRISTIN DAVIS: Issue, really,
there are very, very real
issues to this.
And the worse we let it get,
it's just dumb to let it get
to that point.
Because once it gets to that
point, it's very, very hard to
pull it back.
DIANE SOLINGER: And
now to something
a little more bright.
RAYMOND OFFENHEISER: And what
were we saying to this
Republican group?
I mean, we were basically doing
a couple of things.
One was we were encouraging
support for the president's
initiative on Feed the Future.
President Obama has a big sort
of international agriculture
and food program that
he's been trying
to get through Congress.
There's been a lot
of resistance.
And what is it about?
It's about funding for small
farmer agriculture.
It's about sustaining our
food aid program.
United States has the largest
food aid program in the world.
We provide 50% of the food
aid to emergency
situations around the world.
It's about increasing sort
of entrepreneurship and
investment in entrepreneurship
of the sort
that Susan's doing.
Really important program.
Something that you could
actually encourage your
congressmen in this district,
or your districts in this
general area, to actually
get behind.
And we were challenging them
on the ethanol question.
to take the climate change
challenge real, to see it as a
real challenge that needed to
be confronted.
And we were encouraging them to
think about getting ahead
of the climate change issue by
addressing the question of
whether we need to be investing
in adaptation,
helping some of these contexts
to actually adjust their
farming systems to deal with
the challenges of climate
change, to deal with resilience
and adaptation,
which is sort of the front end
of dealing with climate change
in the short to medium term.
DIANE SOLINGER: Well, and we've
been talking a lot on
the global scale, but it
happens here, in our
backyards, as well.
And you don't think about hunger
in the United States
very much, because we are--
we have an obesity issue,
and a health issue,
and diabetes issues.
But it's very real.
And that's why our food drive
here at Mountain View campus
is so well supported.
Because there's a definite
bifurcation even in our
community of the haves
and have nots.
And I think there needs to be
something that addresses that
gap locally and globally
at the same time.
But Aarti, I love to
cook, as well.
So I think we'll like flank
each other here
at the ends, talking.
But with what you're doing with
the Grow campaign, how
are you engaging
others in that?
Are you bringing in kind
of the concept
into the Food Network?
Are you using that as a platform
to talk about Grow or
about local and meatless
Mondays?
AARTI SEQUEIRA: Yeah.
I mean, meatless Mondays, thank
goodness for whoever
coined that term.
You do some alliteration,
suddenly it's a thing.
But I think that the country as
a whole is already on board
with that, which is
kind of amazing.
At least in terms of, I don't
know if you guys flip through
every food blog that there is,
but every Monday someone has--
Kristin's like, no.
You know, someone's putting
a recipe up.
But I think it is giving people
recipes, and putting
ideas out there.
And helping people understand,
OK, I'm going to go with you,
and I'm going to go to
the farmer's market.
And beets are on sale.
So what do I do?
Buy five pounds of beets?
Yes, you do.
And then what do you
do with them?
DIANE SOLINGER: You don't
waste them at
the end of the week.
AARTI SEQUEIRA: You
don't waste them.
DIANE SOLINGER: You put
them on your pasta.
AARTI SEQUEIRA: Yes.
And you eat the greens, too.
Because they're wicked good
for you, and tasty.
But yeah, I think it's just
sort of helping people--
to me, it just keeps coming back
to this, and I don't know
why-- but just feel empowered.
To actually not only have a
wider impact in the world, but
also feel empowered to just
cook the ding dang thing.
DIANE SOLINGER: And it's like
Kristin said, it's a bit of
connecting the dots.
If it is overwhelming,
we don't feel
like we can do a lot.
We can do something.
And to that, wanted to toss it
to you about the great Oxfam
Unwrapped campaign.
KRISTIN DAVIS: Absolutely.
This is something that
we do year round.
But then occasionally, we
do talk about it more.
And this is one of
those times.
We do a really great project,
it's called Oxfam Unwrapped.
And we have a website,
Oxfamgifts.com.
And it's something where
you can go on.
We have a variety of things.
They are very reasonably
priced.
And sometimes, you can send
a goat to someone.
Or you could send worms
to help a farmer
change their soil.
You can send bees.
Bee keeping is a very amazing
business that you can do on
your own if you have the skill
and the basic beginning tools.
One of the--
well, not one.
I've seen so many of
these items in
practice on my travels.
And you kind of taken them
for granted here.
Like, a handful of seeds.
Again, something you
think like, a
handful of seeds, really?
This makes a huge difference,
does it not?
It is amazing.
People do not have access to a
lot of the newer seeds that
have been, through trial and
error, come in to these
heartier seeds.
And that makes a huge difference
to a small farmer.
So we have the training.
People go and educate the
farmers or the women about how
to raise chicks.
That's another amazing skill
set that is very simple.
People can do it at home.
You don't have to leave
your children.
I've seen women have much
smaller but very similar
outcomes as Susan in terms
of their husbands
going no, no, no, no.
And then, these are people, in
the mountains of Mozambique by
Zimbabwe we met women who were
literally living on less than
$2 a month.
Extreme poverty is defined
as less than $2 a day.
These people were living on
less than $2 a month.
I mean, it was extreme.
And they lived in the most
beautiful, beautiful region.
We called it Shangri La.
Yet, they really had nothing.
And they were given
organic seeds.
And they were growing lettuce
bigger than my head.
They were so proud.
They were living on these
steep mountains.
And we taught them irrigation
methods.
And then they were also
raising chicks.
And the husbands had said
no, no, absolutely
not, absolutely not.
My wife does not work.
She is the mother
of my children.
Well, when they got that $20
bill at the end of the month,
they were like, OK!
DIANE SOLINGER: Money
talks, right?
KRISTIN DAVIS: Yeah.
And it was just really
wonderful.
Because that woman, you could
see the pride that she took in
what she had accomplished.
And you would always ask the
women, we always would say,
what did you do with your money
when you had finished
the project and made
the money?
And they would always say, I
bought the school uniform so
my child could go
back to school.
I bought the paper.
So there are things we
take for granted.
If you can't buy your
child paper, your
child can't go to school.
And school is often a tree
they are sitting under.
That is school.
But they can't go if there's
no paper or pencil.
So school books are on
Oxfam Unwrapped.
Really amazing things.
School meals for the children.
Because a lot of the time, they
don't have a good meal,
which we all know you need to
eat to be able to think to be
able to learn.
And the next generation is going
to change the world, as
my young faces now--
DIANE SOLINGER: It gets
them to school.
KRISTIN DAVIS: Exactly, it
gets them to school.
But the little young people
here, you're so adorable.
And it makes me feel hopeful
that you're all interested in
these kinds of things.
But when you're out in the world
you see these little
kids, and you see how much their
mothers really want to
send them to school,
it's really moving.
And it really makes a huge, huge
difference when they are
able to do so.
So there's a lot of things
on Oxfam Unwrapped
related to the kids.
Then there's a lot related
to farmers,
many of whom are women.
Tools, seeds, worms.
Then there's a lot like
ducks, goats, bees.
You can plant a field that
alpaca could graze in.
Because in South America,
you can raise alpaca.
So it's a really fun thing.
And so this is what I get every
year for Christmas.
Because I don't need anything.
I'm incredibly lucky
in my life, as you
all helped make me.
So I need no gifts.
And my family just
gets to pick.
And they all talk like, I'm
going to get her this, I'm
going to get her that.
And they get things that
sometimes go together, which
is really cute, like the
different things that a school
kid would need.
And then the card goes
to the recipient.
And then the gift goes
to people in
need around the world.
And it's a pretty
good feeling.
DIANE SOLINGER: And there's a
way for Googlers here today.
And if you go to the
website, too.
So it's, what was that again?
KRISTIN DAVIS: Oxfamgifts.com.
DIANE SOLINGER: .Com.
We talked about that.
And at the back of the room,
we have a badge to donate.
Oh, it's over there.
So you can swipe your badge.
And you can pick a project,
whether it's--
I think we have goats.
We have school meals for
two children, and bees.
So three Oxfam projects
that you can unwrap
and swipe to give.
And also, we've talked today
high level systemic stuff, how
to cook to make a difference,
how to shop to make a
difference, how to give in a
variety of ways, and how to
help farmers.
And Googlers have 20 hours of
volunteer time off as a
benefit that we want to
encourage you to use.
Whether it's helping at the
biggest, highest level, and
trying to think about systemic
issues that you might be able
to use your brains to support,
or even going out and going to
the food bank and making sure
that somebody gets a meal that
probably wouldn't.
Those opportunities are year
round, so it's not just now.
Use that benefit.
We really want to encourage
you to do that.
And when you do volunteer, when
you volunteer five hours,
we'll match that with $50.
So every five hours gets $50 to
the organization that you
volunteered to.
So use your gift match.
Use your donations for doers.
Use your benefits.
Use your volunteer time off.
That's one of the things
that makes Google
such a great place.
And we hope that you go out and
help with this campaign.
And thank you for being
a part of this today.
KRISTIN DAVIS: You guys are
amazing, I just want to say.
Google culture is amazing.
RAYMOND OFFENHEISER: And maybe
for the activists in the
audience, you can actually
sort of join the sort of
political work of Oxfam
and the Grow campaign.
We actually have in the San
Francisco area an action
corps, people who actually want
to do sort of activist
work on some of the
policy issues.
So that's another option as well
for those folks who want
to do that kind of work.
DIANE SOLINGER: Thanks,
everyone.
KRISTIN DAVIS: Thanks
for coming.
Have a goo day.
Don't get too wet.